it does seem like George Floyd's killing
before our eyes really just stripped
bare any illusions that many people had
you wanna know what my wife and I got no
argument about the other day I had this
older car had to get a new car and I was
like you know up is we should tint the
windows it's a really really light tint
I'm always like no we shouldn't not
right now it doesn't matter what I say
on TV or how much notoriety I get for
what I say at the end of day like I've
been pulled over multiple times in my
life
for driving a suspicious vehicle a
suspicious vehicle and they've been nice
vehicles but suspicious I hope you do
well it's been a really hard time
throughout the country and we're gonna
be talking to someone now who will I
think have a lot of insight to share
he's ESPN broadcast commentator and
former NBA player former college
basketball legend I guess he's still a
legend Jay Williams Jay how are you
brother I'm good man how about yourself
doing well the family's good so you were
in Brooklyn until quite recently is that
right
yeah you know a lot of people decided to
get out of the city a lot of people who
you know very privileged the monetary
value to get out of the city my wife and
I just chose this day we're there for
you know throughout this entire pandemic
which is a little bit uh it's definitely
different being stuck in New York City
with the amount of anxiety that is they
believe on you every single day just
trying to get outside for a breath of
fresh air and then we had one of our
balcony windows that literally just
shattered and it came down and we got
pretty scared because there was no rock
or anything that came through it we
called the cops we thought they thought
it could potentially have been a BB gun
we weren't sure that's that's terrifying
so you have a baby daughter in the house
right yeah we have a
19 month old and then all the protests
and a lot of the some of the ride and
began in our building got a little bit
messed up so it just uh you know became
one of those scenarios where you know
about this Andrea like I had to protect
my family so we partnered up with
another couple and we came up to Maine
for a couple of weeks and her just
staying here and watching from afar and
you know waiting for things that
deescalate oh well I'm glad that you and
your family are safe everyone's okay
everybody's good man very thankful that
everybody's good I feel like overall our
country is moving in a in a interesting
positive direction seeing so many people
come together it's been it's been really
moving man it's just been innately
different to be a part of something like
this I don't know if you feel the same
way it's just it's so cool to so granted
there's as complex because we're still
in the midst of a pandemic and that's a
whole other issue
but it is good to see us be united to a
degree I feel the same way I feel like
this is unprecedented in my lifetime
where so many people have come together
and there's something both tragic and
beautiful about the outpouring of
passion and grief and emotion that I
mean you you saw up close since it
sounds like you were literally within
steps or a stone's throw away from some
of these protests in Brooklyn yeah it's
it was different the vibe was different
you know at that time obviously there's
a lot of pent-up frustration and anger
and I think ultimately you know coming
out of that and a lot more of a peaceful
way but it's it's powerful and I've had
so many conversations Andrew and I think
that the fact that this came together
I've had a lot of raw conversations with
people and you kind of are able to dive
right in to people being real instead of
a lot of the political or social
conjecture that you get with certain
answers where people haven't been as
real with themselves it's been a lot of
dancing before you know we and now we
get a chance to be raw and a little bit
unfiltered if it feels rewarding and
that's what it's so powerful it like it
does seem like George Floyd's killing
before our eyes really just stripped
bare any illusions that many people had
but you know like there are people who I
think might have been resistant to the
reality of police brutality maybe you
know literally like four weeks ago then
now are completely on board with the
fact that this is like moral stain and a
like a scourge that's been killing
people of color for generations and when
I talk to people who are black men
frankly like most of them have told me
that that they were like hit like a
hammer by the the George Floyd video
where we're you know like they felt
anger grief fear you know like it and
and they said that it was like familiar
emotions but amplified past anything
that they'd experienced before it it
really has and it's so funny I've been
calling you a why for a really long time
I get people in Nick names
I've been calling you a why I don't want
to be like if that's not an economy
that's actually much better than the
[ __ ] I called as a kid town that would
amaze me that's what one to talk to you
though that's why I want to talk to you
a why right like it's you you being the
ethnicity that you are running for
president me being you know I know you
felt this I'm curious get your opinion
on this and I know you have questions
for me and I want to ask you questions
but it's you know I didn't I didn't feel
comfortable speaking on so many things
because I was a black man on TV and a
lot of bosses that we had though is
not as diverse it's and you almost feel
to a degree that if you were to take a
step outside the norm of how society
deems you need to communicate things
right it stops your ascension and when
you're in the midst of this reality
about I have a wife
I've kid I have a mother that has gone
through two kidney transplants the
responsibility that comes along with the
work that I have to do it's a
challenging situation that beyond and
how did you how did you deal with that
obviously because you're catering to all
people but so at the same time you're
one of the first to do this from your
position how did you handle that thank
you for asking Jay I had a similar to
what you're describing really over the
year like the two years I ran where you
show up and then you're trying to ascend
and in my case it was like well I need
to try and get noticed but there there
was like this sense of seriousness I
felt like I had to carry with me all the
time because otherwise people would not
take me very seriously and so like I
felt like I was kind of playing a role
and and that there was a concern that if
I went like off script that things were
gonna go poorly for me in my campaign
that like the press was gonna look for
any reason to just [ __ ] ignore me or
whatnot and so it was like well like
let's not give them those reasons
exactly and and then which is kind of
[ __ ] within itself you know but it
is where it is well yeah I mean I'm so
grateful to independent voices who you
know Frant like mainly podcasters or
people that just use their own judgement
who said hey this Andrew yang person has
some really interesting ideas and I did
not feel that to the same extent I think
that's one reason why you and I wanted
to talk is that you know if you have an
hour to sit and talk to someone like a
human being it's just a very very
different format than if it's like you
have a five minute cable news segment
I'm gonna ask you four questions half of
them are gonna be antagonistic you know
like you just feel like you're just
gonna be like like dodging like you know
like like bricks thrown at you
you know figurative bricks obviously so
so it was difficult and the tough part J
was that like I found that if I didn't
embrace my humanity on the trail in some
ways then like we were never gonna have
a prayer and so I needed to actually act
like myself and it was a very hard thing
to act like myself I mean it probably
seemed like that was the natural thing
for me to do from afar but it was
actually very very difficult this
episode yang speaks is brought to you by
stamps.com I don't know if you ever used
stamps calm before but it's a
game-changer
now when you want stamps you can go to
the post office or you can just go to
stamps calm which is what we did and
that was a home run for us so instead of
going to a post office trying to figure
out how many stamps I need how much does
it cost waiting line all that just goes
dance calm figure out entering what you
got to pay what you got to send and you
print stamps at at home it's fantastic
right now listeners to yank speaks get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
so if you mail lots of stuff this is
your chance just go to stamps comm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in yang that stamps
comm enter yang so you know I've gone
through this a lot on my end
you know obviously we're speaking in to
three-minute sound bytes so you know the
sports world which i think is a
microcosm of you know your arena to a
degree with the way media works you know
it's interesting so we'll have like
morning meetings and you know to give
you an analogy you'll have a guy you
know like Jamal Murray who plays for
Denver he might have had a triple-double
that night and Denver maybe plays the
Clippers and Kauai maybe it's doing lobe
management and Paul George is out so
those guys don't play right
and your sender saying yok Jamal Murray
just had a triple-double that's
incredible like he's done something now
not allowed to who I've been able to do
in the NBA but LeBron James and the
Lakers will be playing somebody and say
it's a lower team like a Memphis you
know or Memphis poor example like a
phoenix who's not in the playoffs but
they are now and I know the next day
we're leading with LeBron James like we
are leading with LeBron James regardless
of how crazy Jamal Murray went off he
could have scored 70 that we are going
to leave with LeBron James and I feel
like a lot of times I will watch a lot
of these debates that you were in and I
would hear your points I will write them
down but man that's really this somewhat
genius okay I like the way he's thinking
and the next day sure enough it's like
these political agendas were out there
knowing how these meetings go leading
with other people I'm like oh this is
the same thing as sports this is
interesting well you and I have both
been in the media machine like you see
how those meetings go and then what
stories get produced and you know I
certainly feel like my campaign
definitely demonstrated that you know
like some of the stories had a
pre-written agenda before yeah the
actual event and the fact that happens
in sports is probably not surprising to
two fans and and people who watch it
every day like I do people you mean you
know I'm a big sports fan and know when
I talk to you and other are there black
athletes like that one of the things
that like I sensed is this anguish that
like it doesn't matter how much you
ascend how you know wealthy or
successful you are that at the end of
the day like when you're driving your
car and you're a person of color like
the police officer doesn't know who you
are and like there's a sense that you're
still on guard you wanna know what my
wife and I got an argument about the
other day
so I was talking to one of my really
good friends his name was Matt Clauberg
and I was like you know okay like I had
this older car had to get a new car and
I was like you know up we should tint
the windows just a really really light
tint and my wife's like no we shouldn't
not right now and my wife's Lebanese in
Italian okay so like no it's okay like
it'll be it'll be fine
she's like no I just I don't feel
comfortable with you doing that in like
Dola to the type of conversations that I
end up having that it doesn't matter how
successful I get it doesn't matter what
I say on TV or how much notoriety I get
for what I say at the end of the day
like I've been pulled over multiple
times in my life for driving a
suspicious vehicle a suspicious vehicle
and they've been nice vehicles but
suspicious and that's led to I mean
things that my dad and I have talked
about Andrew is you know when you get
pulled over you keep both your hands on
the wheel you do not move you try to use
tonality that de-escalate situations
regardless of how the cop might try to
escalate it or ask you questions or try
to catch you out there and when you go
to your glove compartment to get your
insurance or your registration you keep
one hand on the will and you you it's
called a guide hand you guide the cop
with you as you're maintaining eye
contact with him about where your hand
is going and I can't tell you how many
times this happened to me and I've been
pulled over with other friends and I've
seen some other friends who are
Caucasian you know throw a hissy fit and
the cop is trying to cut and I'm like
wow I don't have that same luxury even
if I did the anxiety I would have
because I know that's not the norm just
gives it such a different feel all the
time all the time yeah that's something
that most of us can't relate to or
people that didn't grow up black in this
country you know and have that kind of
experience certainly you know like this
time is highlighted for us all just how
completely and destructively racist a
lot of police behavior is you know when
I started digging into the facts around
this and I knew a lot from my time the
on the campaign trail but the magnitude
of the problem is is highlighted by the
fact that we don't even know precisely
how big the problem is
it's like like there have been multiple
laws that were passing hey we should try
and document how many people died as a
result of encounters with police are in
police custody and we still don't
actually get that information from
police departments around the country we
like there were journalists who compiled
it locally and so to me
most Americans cannot relate to that but
if you are a person of color growing up
in this country it's just a reality that
you've lived with for your entire life
yeah so I didn't even know and with you
it has been my reality so I look at the
situation in Minnesota and I'm like you
know is that what we should require our
police force to do like you know it'd be
dismantled and then built from the floor
up but then you know who's still
policing the neighborhood's while you're
dismantling the police force I and I've
heard a lot people talk about we need to
defund the police is is that the answer
how would you how would you go about it
because I obviously have way more
experience in this and I do well defund
the police is just the wrong term for
what people are arguing people are
arguing for scaling up resources to
communities around health care and
education and mental health resources
and infrastructure and community
services and scale down the level of of
policing and Minneapolis is step to
defund what they did was it looks like
they're gonna disband the police
department which is an incredibly
dramatic step it happens almost never in
the United States but it did happen to a
town that you probably know relatively
well it happened in Camden New Jersey
because the Camden police department was
so corrupt that they got there and
eventually said there is no saving this
department like there's no turning this
thing around there was so much so much
corruption going on that in like if I
told you like the stories and the news
accounts that were they were literally
just like passing the drugs around and
like showing oh like everyone knew what
was going on and so they had to disband
that police department and then when
they reconstituted it they hired back
some of the same police officers but
they had a completely different approach
to policing where the policeman
volunteered in communities they had
barbecue
use if you're a new police officer in
that department you have to knock on
every door of the places you're
patrolling and just introduce yourself
and say hi say hey I'm the police I
actually actually know your neighbor yes
sir that we'll be patrolling in this in
this area so they've done very dramatic
things now Camden was an unusual example
but it seems like Minneapolis is trying
to do something similar and no like the
fact that they did this to me
is a major step and other communities
are going to look at this and say wait
like that's actually even conceivable
because most of us can't imagine a
police department being disbanded but it
has happened multiple times in the u.s.
so like I don't know all right if that's
the case but maybe they are being a
little bit dramatic then what's an
immediate solution like obviously yeah
you know I see a lot of activation
around local legislation where people
like you know who's your district
attorney who's your mayor what are some
of the policies they put in place
obviously do more research on that is
that the immediate answer to go more
grassroots and try to have more people
that look and sound like minorities in
government positions because I don't
know if that's always the answer either
because I know a lot of people that are
corrupted by these same situations so
what would you advise people to do
currently now this was Cornel West right
after the the riot the protest began
where he said look we've tried black
faces in high places and it has not
actually changed like what's happening
on the streets and so there there are a
number of big changes that are being
proposed that would move in the right
direction so number one is use of force
rules saying look no chokeholds
deescalate like use of force of exhaust
every other alternative just change the
rules and standards and that apparently
would have a very dramatic effect on
fatality rates having greater federal
oversight because the local district
attorney is not going to want to pick
fight with the local police officers
like the local police officers are some
of the most powerful people in the
community like sometimes the most
powerful people and so that so you need
some kind of Department of Justice
oversight that has made a difference in
the past having people that you can call
it or not police officers it's actually
very helpful one out of every four
people that get shot by a police officer
is mentally ill and if you can imagine
police officers showing up and saying
well you're not listening to my commands
like halt or I'll shoot and then like
something tragic happens instead you
send in a crisis worker and a mental
health worker and a medic for those
situations who don't have guns obviously
so that would be a change the toughest
change that I think is going to be
imperative is that there are these
police union rules that make it so that
a lot of police aren't really
accountable when they do something wrong
and police unions are very very powerful
politically in otherwise monetarily and
so changing those rules is going to be a
very very difficult process but I think
that's an enormous help right now
police departments get hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of military
gear from the Department of Defense no
charge and studies have shown that if
you get those weapons you use them
occasionally there's actually a
provision in the law that says if you
don't use that in the course of a year
you have to give it back so if you get a
tank and grenade launchers you literally
are like all right I guess I have this
stuff and so every once in a while you
end up using it in communities in a way
that leads to loss of life so these are
some of the things that that people are
trying to take aim at the biggest one is
just tracking bad cops because right now
if you have a bad cop they can literally
quit go to counties over and then just
get rehired and there's actually no way
of tracking that cops history or
behavior so how is that possible though
how is there no way of tracking it well
there's no national database of like so
if I'm a police officer I mean in theory
you'd call the old department and be
like hey like you know like why is this
guy not with you
but but there there is no database
there's no tracking and a lot of that
time J like these complaints because of
Union rules are confidential
and so so Derek Chavan the guy who
killed George Floyd had 18 complaints
against him and if you look at that and
say like [ __ ] that's like a ton of
complaints like this guy's a real
history he was like present for the
deaths of multiple suspects over time
and these are the kinds of things that
generally speaking no action is being
taken on right now around the country
for some of these reasons so so these
are some of the policies that people are
trying to legislate for or agitate for
new legislation the defund the police
movement is itself you know like should
we be investing more in communities of
color in particular 100% yes are we
overspending on police objectively in my
opinion yes but the the defund the
police statement is not helpful because
it literally sounds like you want to
zero out like police departments which
is not actually the goal okay so come
with me here so if you're saying that
defunding the police department is not
the right direction you still want to do
things within the in the communities you
know I've been reading a lot about this
act HR 40 I don't know if you heard
about that where it talks about
reparation and it's been interesting to
me a why to to read up a lot about
Germany who's become one the most
progressive countries there's in the
world by the way and you know when you
see signs in Berlin that reminds you of
the Holocaust and talk about it and the
fact that they've been paying reparation
for close to 100 years to the Jewish
community and you know it it used to
seem like such a lofty goal to me such a
lofty thing and then recognizing that
other countries have been doing it why
is that not something that you think
we're not hearing as much about is that
just because we can't is that a topic
that
people just don't want to out even know
why they wouldn't talk about this
because I I barely hear it and then it
loses steam HR 40 is a great effort in
Congress to try and examine what the
heck reparations would look like in
practice and I've read tondc Coates and
other people who argue really
compellingly that reparations is
something that's owed to descendants of
slaves in the US and you know you can't
you can't argue with the fact that this
country was built on the backs of slaves
so the fact that other countries have
done it is awesome and the fact the
United States is not at this point
really having a conversation about that
is something that I hope will change
over time to me one of the goals that
has to be to try to eradicate poverty
right now for everyone and then I think
we can look at reparations very
seriously to me preparations is more
possible in a country where people feel
like their needs are being met do you
think that your strategy currently for
the time that we're in would have been
beneficial how would that worked oh you
know people say to me all the time Jay
that's like if all of this [ __ ] hit the
fan
you know like ten weeks earlier I'd be
the front runner today I don't mean that
that's something that I hear a lot of
and you know I mean it's heartbreaking
that we're in this situation with like a
crisis on top of a crisis and certainly
like you like I just want to do
everything I can to help right now but I
will say that millions of Americans got
$1200 stimulus checks from the
government and they were like wait a
minute we can do that like and they
liked getting the same in this checks
that helped them breathe easier and made
them less stressed out and so there are
a lot of people joining yangyang all the
time honestly like you know you look at
our mailing list and like supporter base
and the rest of it it's growing all the
time because a lot of people are like
wait a minute
like that guy actually made a lot of
sense and a lot of the stuff he
described is coming to pass
unfortunately faster than even I'd
imagine
it's uh it's interesting even you know
being on air every day I took about four
or five days off obviously got my family
out of town when all the protests
started to happen in the riot and got up
here and got settled but it was
interesting there was such this rush I
felt to hurry up and get back on air and
you know everybody saying you're Jay we
want you on air your voice is important
and I said I understand that but you
know there's a lot of weight that comes
along with with the position that I'm in
and I want to thoroughly think through
what it is I want to say and what the
impact of what I'm going to say is going
to have and actually want there to be
actionable items that when I do go on
air I'm just not pontificating about how
frustrated I am or how pissed off I am
I've been that way for a long time I've
been that way since watching my dad deal
with cops and you know then you combine
that with the pandemic is um you know I
it was it was challenging for me because
as a black man I'm supposed to do that
that is my that is my role that is my
responsibility and trying to work with
people on a day to day basis to help me
think through what it is I want to say
and how I want to say it you know
collection of data you know who do you
use for stuff like that and you
obviously me you can't come up with all
this stuff on your own I would say got
your team but who are some of the people
that you talk to that you bounce ideas
off of that you think are your trusted
you know internal circle one thing
that's fun about being me now J and this
applies for it to you just as much is
that just about anyone will talk to you
like you know like if you reach out to
campaign zero or police equity or like
the frankly these like black activists
who've been trying to figure out okay
how the heck do we make the police less
lethal for people of color like that the
evidence and research and the policies
like I just listed to you they're not
mine they're from campaign zero these
black activists DeRay McKesson and
Samuel I'm gonna mangle Sam's last name
but but okay I'll look it up can't
answer no man I'll send you the links in
the info but it's tremendous because
they've done the work and then you know
then I kick the tires on the work
they've done and look at it and say well
one the date is there too it's common
sense you know and and so so that that
is the fun part of being US J is like
you know we can equip ourselves pretty
quick because everyone wants to tell us
what they've been working on and then
you and I have the benefit where we can
spread that message yeah I think that's
the point you know and it's a I try to
tell people we were on air the other day
and I was like hey look these next four
and a half months just go ahead and
buckle up Andrew like buckle up brother
like it's gonna be a ride on a sports
side I can talk about this is that you
know having the NBA playoffs that are
about to happen in that condensed time
period starting in July ending in
October having MLB that's coming into
its own if they're able to get through
it
athletes are gonna have the biggest
state the biggest stage they've ever had
in their entire lives and you can bet
your tail on it that guys are gonna be
speaking out now having a
commander-in-chief that likes to engage
in the sports arena and I've had this
issue at ESPN it was tough I mean look
people are going to talk about Jamel
Hill and Michael Smith to people I got
let go by ESPN for speaking out their
mind against him and everybody got put
in this really weird situation about you
know we are for sports we're not for
politics but then you're like how do you
navigate you know he keeps injecting
himself into these conversations and
using things to politicize and weaponize
and this go be a fight people were fans
about to see a fight for the next four
and half months on a pretty massive
stage it's gonna be crazy to watch you
know one thing I know you're outspoken
about which I am 100% with you on is
that college athletes need to get
compensated for the revenues and the
talents they're bringing in and to me
there's always been a racial component
to this because you have Dee
football players and basketball players
often people of color who are not
getting paid they're getting these
scholarships and then you have these
coaches and athletic directors often
commanding seven-figure salaries often
not people of color and and then you
have these institutions that are
benefiting to the tune of tens of
millions of dollars year broadcast
contracts that are worth hundreds of
millions and to me there was always like
this it was like an oppression not just
of young people but also a people of
color who are generating the value
risking life and limb you know and then
being told it's like hey you're getting
this great education out of it so just
be grateful shut up
you can't like if you if you took money
from anyone then we're somehow going to
take away your eligibility and you're
building a play because you have like
poked a hole and this [ __ ] fiction
that like you're all amateurs and like
like we're all amateurs too like your
coaches are doing it for the love of the
game and the like freaking 4 million
dollars a year they get paid so like
this to me has always been like the
biggest sack of [ __ ] that you can
see in like the the you know
institutional frameworks where it's like
wait a minute like how much dudes I on
just make four for his school or like
the broadcast networks I'm like how much
did he get I mean you know like I
imagine Sian was okay but you know I
mean like it but it the thing that
worries me really is like that person
who's not a household name who's not
gonna make the league who's like you
know they're and like is going to have a
hard time in like their post athletic
career after school who should have been
compensated for the value of they were
adding when they were in school man you
know we've been talking about this
forever and here people combat that same
you know thought that you had with well
you know I'm still paying back my
student loans and I would say I
understand the value of education and I
you know look that's a whole other
different conversation about education
when we can get into that and a little
bit but I'm like I understand what the
the
issues are around that and how
challenging that might be but I also
understand that you know I brought in
millions of dollars of revenue million
in you know cable companies is just in
the hundreds of millions it's in its
billions
I mean it's billions is ten that billion
dollars in which the n-c-double-a
tournament got so for and you just you
see guys like Zion Williamson's to
beginning of residual check every every
other week just sort of notoriety he
could bring to the table and so for me
personally and the tonality of it to a
why it's like predominantly these kids
in both these footballs that generate
enough money for to subsidize all the
other sports they're african-american so
then when you're able to say okay at the
University when there's an issue you you
have the athletic director that speaks
out about the issue for the university
when the coach has an issue either the
coach can speak out or the coach's agent
could speak out when the league has an
issue the Commissioner of the league can
speak out well when a player has an
issue
who's speaking out and the players
behalf nobody and oftentimes the player
doesn't say anything because the player
wants to be able to get the leeway to go
to another University for a second try
and doesn't want to have that university
taint his you know resume on who he is
as a person so the fact that you have
all these individuals that have no
representation in the marketplace but
yet it's called amateurism and people
don't even know where amateurism came
from I mean it came from the 50s with
the first director of the n-c-double-a
Walter Byers there was a player who was
running a slant route for a smaller
school got hit running a slant route
catching the ball and got hit helmet no
helmet passed away the his wife at the
time tried to sue the school for workers
comp they found a loophole around
workers comp because he was not an
employee he was deemed an amateur so you
know when you understand where this
terminology came from and then you see
how much it's evolved and the fact that
now we're finally on the you know verge
of getting name image and likeness and
how that's a fight is beyond me
absolutely it's like people are like
paying for
you know for the videogame to be able to
play you you know like the jerseys the
autographs and everything else you can't
even have that like that to me was like
the most ridiculous stance I'm glad
that's changing but you know that but
that's not where all the money is really
I mean the money is hovering around
these broadcasting deals I mean what a
what a crazy concept right rev-share I
mean what a crazy concept I mean that's
what the NBA does that's what and it
fell does
that's what MLS does that's what MLB
does so why is the inside of a any
different I mean even if you want to put
that money and Ruane escrow and even if
you were to break it down and say okay
we're gonna put a small percentage of
this money for the profit that your own
athletic department for basketball
generates we're gonna you know we still
have to subsidize other sports I know a
lot of schools are breaking even but a
lot of schools are not who are way more
profitable and in the public eye a ton
so even if we were to give you up a
sliver of that a smaller percentage and
say let's keep this in escrow and if you
graduate maintaining a certain GPA buy
this new curriculum that we're going to
establish that's actually going to be
conducive to you being successful once
you graduate from here other than you're
just taking lame courses because
basketballs your priority yes or your
sport is your priority because you can't
major in what you actually want to major
in even though we're gonna call you a
student-athlete the reality is you're an
athlete student so but we came in come
to an agreement on that like if you had
like an escrow account where people were
getting some of the revenue down the
road even like you said like that would
be an amazing for so many athletes and
they deserve it I mean it was their
freakin talent energy and dedication
with that man generated the value that
right now the schools are all are
benefiting from yeah so I mean that's
it's we're on that trajectory it's going
to be even more interesting you know
because this is already happening on the
high school level you know with all
these different social media platforms
you have kids now who are starting to
think about themselves as businesses at
a lot earlier of a stage if you see kids
on YouTube who are 10 11 years old who
are making
of dollars based upon how many views
they get and how YouTube is taking that
or that matrix right yeah or these
skipping college they're just going
straight to the jeely yeah they're like
wait a minute I can make a quarter mil
plus maybe some sponsorship and
endorsement can build my brand and the
rest of it like you know they don't need
to put up with the NCAA's [ __ ]
anymore like it's not working I'm with
him and it's so it's gonna get it's
gonna get even more progressive because
there's no other choice this episode is
brought to you by the Jordan Harbinger
show so Jordan armature is one of those
realistic self-improvement guys where if
you listen to his show you actually get
things you can apply to your life as
opposed to oh that's inspirational oh
that's it makes me feel good no it
actually is practical information for
example well my favorite shows are
episodes he's done is with this guy
named Justin Ramsdale who talked about
how you can detect and disarm
pseudoscience so you guys all know
you're reading articles and it says this
study says X my own people do this and
this study says why mountain people do
bla how do you know it's real how do you
know it's not this has practical
information how do you detect that how
do you tell if it's fake and how do you
understand where the truth is which is a
challenge in today's media climate the
other episode he has on there recently
was with Mark Cuban our boy we just had
on here and I listened to Mark Cuban
talk about anything that guy is
fascinating to me check out the Jordan
Harbinger show Jordan Harbinger calm
sigh subscribe on Apple Spotify wherever
you get your podcasts what's next for
you like what what are what are some of
andrew Yang's actionable items in the
next couple of years what things would
you like to achieve I want to achieve so
much Jay because we're falling apart and
one of the things that this actually
ties is back to what you were just
saying we're in like the age of
institutional failure you know like you
look up and you see an institution it is
not doing very well right now and our
trust in institutions is also collapsing
it's like you rewind a couple
generations ago everyone thought May it
might have thought like hey the NCAA is
like a okay and then
now we're like what the hell like what
are you doing you know the police with
the killing of George Floyd our
government the media
you name it at this point we're like
questioning everything and with good
reason and if you are an athlete at a
college you know no one stands up for
you no one represents you and you know
if you come out and talk about certain
things you're gonna be labeled what a
distraction like not a team player or
you're bad apple you're like not part of
the team you know and and and that that
pressure extends into the corporate
realm to like for many many folks who
are like you know representing different
backgrounds in these organizations it's
like well you know it's like you want to
be you but like you don't want to
undermine whatever the heck like the
like the corporate picture is like if
you are a certain certain firm and let's
say you have major advertisers who like
you know throw off like like hundreds of
millions of dollars it's like when Bill
Simmons was like criticizing the NFL and
we're like hand in glove and then just
like don't bite the hand that feeds you
and so like there's all of this like oh
[ __ ] the one like who's the hand can I
not bite like what's going on but but
like the these things that would have
happened behind closed doors a
generation ago now we can all see like
we can all see glimpses of or clearly
because of Technology and social media
one thing I said before is that like the
illusions are dying the question is what
takes their place and can we stand the
truth when it's shown to us so for me
over the next couple of years I just
want to try and get us through this
period Jay because it's a disastrous
time for so many Americans right now
it's so bad you know you're looking at
40 million jobs lost that we know of at
least forty percent of which are not
going to come back so you're looking at
16 million jobs gone for good that's two
times the Great Recession we're looking
at depression-era levels of unemployment
and but the vast majority of Americans
support cash relief right now and
Congress is not passing it if you look
at three trillion or so that's already
been spent on stimulus maybe ten percent
of it was in the form of cash to people
ninety percent of it went to bailout you
know what have you like the airlines or
various big companies banks whatever you
know it's like money is just getting
plowed through these pipes and a lot of
it's not reaching people you know it's
like who if you don't have that we smoke
we saw that with these small business
loans they were so small out towards
small businesses that uh went to a lot
bigger small businesses and didn't go to
the actual small businesses yeah and
then just ran out and someone said
something you know I was talking to
Mark Cuban about this but he said like
why do you even have a limit on this
fund it's like if literally you're just
trying to support small businesses like
you have a small business qualifies
likes given the money like like what's
the point of having a pool that gets
exhausted and gets exhausted by like the
shake Shack's of the world and [ __ ] you
know I mean no another you get Shake
Shack you know I love Shake Shack but
you know I like the big company that you
know it doesn't need it and and I did
not fault the big companies who applied
and got the money because the the pots
there for you you qualify you've got a
banker you can call up like you get the
money you know it's like it's not the
big company's fault for taking advantage
of a program that's been put out there
for them it's the fault of our
government for designing a program
really poorly and and seeing to it that
like the biggest get to feed first every
time I hear you talk he just makes too
much sense like you make too much sense
so like did you did you how did you deal
with I'm sure there were some racial
things thrown at you throughout the
course of your campaign I mean there was
but I will say Jay when I was out
campaigning around the country I did not
get much of that like most Americans
we're very open minded to me certainly
to my face like I don't know what
happened like you know as soon as I
leave but like like when I was there
there was like a real warmth and
openness to to many of the gatherings to
the extent that I was frustrated with my
treatment it really was
in the media and I think that like that
was tied to my race
honestly like like that there was like
this invisibility that I was like what
the [ __ ] I'm standing right here and
like it happened to be frequently enough
where I was like oh this is certainly
not just me imagining [ __ ] and and I
think a significant amount of it was the
fact that I'm an Asian American and you
know like people weren't accustomed to
having an Asian person trying to raise
their hand and saying like hey I've got
like I've got the solutions or like I
think I know where we need to go so that
was a frustration of mine but it's been
invigorating that you know the this
movement has been growing really ever
like even after I suspended my campaign
like I feel like our energy is higher
now than it was even like when I was
campaigning and I don't want to over and
in it inundate you questions but it's a
you know we this is our first time
really talking and sometimes I know what
a lot of my friends and I talked about
is that look I am independent and you
know Charlamagne is is a friend of mine
Karen Kenny who kind of works with us
both is our light and we had
conversations all the time about you
know the Democratic Party and how
they've been able to utilize the black
vote in a lot of ways you know I think a
lot of black people felt let down is is
there a chance for a third party that
potentially could be established one day
a Y and maybe is there why would you
filter out having better candidates I'm
not saying that our candidates that we
have Joe body is lacking that's a whole
other conversation that we cannot sure
we can even get into that but is is that
feasible so the mechanics of a third
party are very very difficult J if you
look at it like if someone ran as an
independent I actually talked to mark
cuban about this because he was looking
at a presidential run and he's a smart
guy savvy guy and he dug in and found
the same thing I did about the mechanics
is like running right now as a third
party is a great way to help someone
else win it's not
going to result in your victory and
that's the reality right now that I
think we need to change because I think
that two-party duopoly is destroying us
in some ways I think there are many
people who do not feel like either party
speaks for them right now people who
identify as independence which I think
you may identify as outnumber are
they're Democrats or Republicans but by
the numbers but there isn't a party for
you so you're just like all right I
guess I'm going to choose one of these
two and so the big reform that would
help us advance politically is
rank-choice voting where if you could
just say look you're a few people I like
I like yank first and then you know Joe
second and then Elizabeth Warren third
or whatever the list is and then people
wouldn't feel like they were forced to
vote for a particular person people
wouldn't feel like they were ever gonna
waste their vote and then you could have
people's true preferences get laid out
and it would make politicians much more
responsive and politics much more
dynamic because you'd wind up with then
with like a more parliamentary system
where you'd have splinter parties that
then had like a degree of support so if
you had rank choice voting then you
could potentially have more parties but
the way it's set up right now with just
this one vote use it or lose it or not
it's like it's it's called like first to
the post like first a 51% is the
technical term for our current voting
system is very very hard for an
independent party right now and you know
that's just the way our system set up
which is not deliberate like the
Constitution has zero language about oh
they're gonna be two political parties
like and and there are points in the
past where there were multiple political
parties like there were major parties
that now don't even exist like the Whigs
you know no one even like [ __ ] thinks
about though the Whigs but if you guys
like a big deal so so that there there's
a need for dynamism in our political
system but it's unclear where that comes
from and there are a lot of people like
you and maybe Charlemagne and maybe
others who are looking up saying like we
need like
better system than this like I went
through the Democratic nomination
process and like on one level I really
might appreciate the fact that you know
I was included in stuff you know like
and like had in some ways like a you
know like a fair shot but there were
other times where was like man like this
process is really not designed for
someone to come in from outside that the
fear Jay is that DC right now is on a
30-year lag time behind the rest of the
country and we don't have 30 years to
wait and and that's just the situation
we're in where if someone like me wanted
to try and make changes in the
Democratic Party it would take a
significant amount of time and the
question is whether we have that much
time
I mean yeah that is the question so
looking at the reality of the situation
I mean is is Joe Biden gonna have a
black woman with him to be the vice
president of the United States is that
the most suitable is that Camello Harris
is you know who do you think is the most
suitable candidate for that if you ask
me is Joe going to have a black woman
running mate I would guess that yes he
will and then there are several top
candidates for that come align know and
consider her friend I don't know some of
the other people that are in the running
but I think that's what you'll see and I
I believe that Joe is going to win I
think that Trump is alienating a lot of
people that were you know like that
voted for him and we're like you know
pretty much they were justifying their
continued support for him based upon
their 401k stock market and jobs they
were like oh he's doing a great job of
the economy and that argument is not
going to work for many many people this
time because you know there's gonna look
around the town and being like you know
like the like the like the bar is
half-empty the you know like the rental
car agencies like half occupied like it
you know it's not a good look for him
oh it's interesting because every
morning you wake up you watch a lot of
shows and you know I watch everything
from from MSNBC to Fox to you know I
listen to a ton of different networks to
try to get alternate opinion so I can
come to my own assessment but it's like
you know on one end ooh you hear every
morning like this daunting thing like
you know unemployment unemployment in
numbers are astronomical and then on
another you hear well the stock market
is up right even though the two don't
really correlate like how do you is a
stock market being up is that
sustainable does that does that help
Donald Trump better because the
economy's in that place yeah I mean it's
marginally helpful for for Donald Trump
because people at least feel like their
stock portfolios are going up but right
now the problem is that stock prices and
unemployment now have no relationship at
all like if you fire a lot of people
your stock price probably goes up
because I go good you got rid of people
so the issue is whether more people own
stock or have jobs and it's many many
many more people have jobs than own
stock so like the fact that the
employment picture is really bleak is
going to impact a lot of people very
very harshly and negatively and then
there's going to be a relatively small
percentage of Americans who are just
staring at the stock price and their
jobs are fine and you know that that
describes you and me obviously but it
does not describe the majority of
Americans about half of Americans own no
stock so you know they don't care about
stock market prices and the the top 20
percent of Americans own 92 percent of
the stock portfolio so so for better for
worse Jay the people that you hang out
with that own a lot of stock around the
top 20% of the US population and which
is not shocking because you know like
you are who you are like you know you're
hanging out with people who work at ESPN
or athletes or whatnot it's like I mean
obviously I have like a freaking you
know financial like well you know like
team there I am NOT there yeah I I
witnessed that from afar I'm like oh
you're making how much of your
interesting okay not there so so yeah
the stock market prices and jobs are
heading in opposite directions and the
jobs are going to her
more people than the stock market
praises gonna help so if we're having a
balance she issue how come you don't see
the government do things like legalize
marijuana or legalized gambling in order
to capitalize on that tax revenue they
really should why is it yeah it just
makes sense doesn't it yeah I think that
for marijuana
it's like residual cultural issues and
probably racism and it's like that's the
only explanation I can see gambling is a
different issue there are some corporate
interests in gambling who like the
current state of affairs where you know
that like they profit from having
gambling be legal only and like very
expensive licenses for legalizing online
poker that's for sure like that makes no
sense where you know it's cuz like then
right now you can still gamble you have
to gamble do some weird Offshore's site
and that's lost tax revenue it's less
safe for people you know it's like not
as much transparency around the odds
like you don't know if they're cheating
you so so that one we should do for sure
are you a poker player I am I mean I
know how to play I'm not like someone
who said sitting there like you know
making the magic I have friends who are
very high-level poker players like I
don't know you know like Daniel Negreanu
he was like yang gang had an event for
me in Vegas which I appreciate
yeah that there's a so yeah like I mean
I understand it but like a lot of
friends who are really into it though
there's like this this this like overlap
I'm sure between like sports and betters
and like some you should've seen how
many times when I was in college my
friends are like you know what this
spread is tonight I'm like what stop no
I don't want to why would you tell that
to me I'm around a lot of degenerates in
that way but they're my boy so that's
what it is
[Music]
[Applause]
we interrupt this fantastic podcast to
bring you a word from our sponsor you
Nagi scooters and these things are
freaking awesome so you Nagi sends you
the scooter in the mail it comes in this
like Apple iPhone beautiful packaging
box situation it's sleek it's easy
assemble like sets up pretty
automatically it's already charged and
these things can fly they look good they
feel good they're a ton of fun my sister
and I have been riding this around our
neighborhood during quarantine and now
I've moved back to Manhattan and I'm
riding around on the sidewalk and it's a
blast get yours at unagi scooters calm
that's un AGI scooters calm and if you
use the discount code yang you get $150
off the unagi a 500 and holy crap this
thing will change your life because it's
just so much freaking fun like you just
feel like you're in the future look like
a badass feel like a badass like a magic
carpet it's awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
well well one of the things I admire so
much about you Jay is that you are like
the highest level athlete in high school
college number two overall pick you know
and then you went through like a ton of
adversity and have now like reinvented
yourself you know as like a TV
personality commentator or business
person and everything else and like I
know a lot of former athletes and it's
really really hard for many athletes to
find like that next chapter or like the
next set of things that they do so the
fact that you've succeeded at such a
high level already and you have like so
much ahead of you
I mean like you're a tremendous role
model oh thank you man
and I really appreciate you allowing you
know me to ask you those questions I
feel so much more informed going back
into the world and it's a you know for
me personally a why it's like you know
seeing you on your journey I find a lot
of similarities right it's you know you
going through and I just want to give
credence to to you here and for people
listening you know to do what you're
doing it takes a lot of courage right it
takes a lot of courage and I've always
felt that you spoke when you spoke it
came from a place like this is how I
feel and I'm sure there are a lot of
moments that you know do to the lane in
which you were running that you had to
think through a lot of different
obstacles and challenges about maybe
what the system wanted you to do as
opposed to what you wanted to do and I'm
sure that was difficult and navigate to
difficult to navigate but ultimately men
like you are you are courageous for
stepping yourself out there and you know
your family and speaking out for what
you believe in and that you know from
somebody who's had to learn how to do
that in front of the public like I had
to find out I think the reason why I am
the way I am today is that I had to find
out who I was as a human being in front
of the camera and I had to recognize
that that is an ongoing process
sometimes you might get lost in debates
or things and I'm quick to tell people
if I was wrong I'm quick to tell people
what I've learned because I I want you
to enjoy this ride with me because
you're in the same journey you know you
today it's completely different I'm sure
than you two years ago and if we're
lucky enough to be here man
we'll be remissed if we didn't pay
attention to the things that are
happening along the way so I commend you
for that brother I really do
Thank You Jay certainly it's all about
discovering our own humanity you know
and in our case we're doing it in front
of a lot of people you know which is its
own process but we have to humanize this
country we have to humanize our economy
we have to humanize certainly the way
police interact with us and particularly
people of color like that that's really
the challenge in front of us and like
you and I have succeeded in a way that
like it's elevated you into this like
machinery and so now you like see the
machinery and you're like oh my gosh
like look at all this stuff and then
you're like how am I gonna humanize this
quite difficult to humanize but but but
that is the project of this era and
you're gonna be a big part of that I
hope to be a big part of that but people
need us because like that like we're
getting ground up you know it's like
like humanity is losing and this set of
protests to me is like a like a cry of
anguish and grief and anger and passion
of humanity it's like you know like one
of us was killed in front of our eyes
like you know our leaders are not really
listening to us and responding to us
like we are going to make our voices
heard and I know that's going to be your
job in my job in different ways over the
the days and years to come
well I look forward to our relationship
build a man I really do and you know
maybe you know once we continue to
evolve as a country when we find
ourselves and a little bit better of a
place hopefully the numbers go down I
know there's been a lot of protests out
there that's also something for people
to pay very close attention to these
spikes in different parts of the country
but if we can pull through a love to
meet up with you man go SIA get you down
to become a Brooklyn
that's fan we need some more fans in
Brooklyn literally it was like just
talking to some of the Nets team I know
you obviously live there and so you're a
fan you probably are friends with I know
you're friends with Cady and some of the
other players too so like are you like
hardcore Brooklyn Nets well I was a
hardcore New Jersey Nets guy yeah yes
throwback and it just so happened that
they moved to Brooklyn and you know my
wife and I were in Brooklyn too so it
kind of feels just very close to my
heart you know it's hard to be a Knicks
fan these days hard to be divorced the
Knicks in 2014 and then there was a
period when I was like you know looking
for a team and we scooped you up we took
you on a date and we scooped you up yeah
they're like I was trying I gotta admit
the first time there is a little bit
like I mean I've never been divorced
thank God real life but like like that
the first time I was trying like trying
a new team on it was really freaking
weird because like I was used to the
Guardian I was used to like the the
court and the play-by-play and like
everything and so hanging out on
Barclays at first I was like well this
is cool like I get used to this and like
but it was like I was hard but but but
but now you know I'm a nets fan and like
been enjoying it and you know it's
helped that the team's been good and
interesting and well coached you know
and and well-managed and now I'm
actually friends with some of the owners
so like when when I come to the game
like I just did you know Josiah and
Claire are great they're great yeah
they're great and they're great
like donated my you know PPE and money
and I you know I don't know if you saw
this Jay but like burn that all in
challenge thing it's like I gave away
courtside Mets tickets with with me so
maybe you'll be there for that too maybe
we'll do some kind of crazy joint like
you know I'll do it I'll do it because
we have four C's to so I'll do it with
you that would be so much fun
so that that's a date you know that's
something for us to look forward to
after all of this the smoke clears
amen well I really appreciate you giving
me the time a wife and I'm glad you've
allowed me to give you the nickname a
white ooh that's pretty
I love it again man vastly superior to a
lot of the stuff I've been called to
saying one day if you ever get to the
White House my daughter seems like a
wife like that's right the president has
a nickname that is right and your dad
gave it to me
all the best to you and the family and
we'll catch up soon in person man I'll
send you some of the stuff too cuz like
I can tell you're into it
our brothers stay safe and thank you for
all the informative stuff that you give
me man I will definitely check out
campaign zero for sure thanks Jay all
the best man take care